Oh
some of the major issues are I think
stereo Tippi you know especially younger
people I mean there's you know there's
all kinds of jokes about that but you
know whatever I guess I won't cite cite
the jokes but you know just just the the
hue the humorous view that older people
even would be sexually active but for
for older individuals themselves I guess
one of the biggest issues is having a
partner because you know if you know
anything about the demographics of Aging
it's a predominantly female population I
think when you get to age 100 it's about
ten to one I think females to males but
even younger than that you know women
live longer than men so so for a lot of
people you know who've lost their
partner just having a partner is a big
issue so you know that's one issue then
I think what people think about mostly
when they think about sexuality and the
elderly is you know if you lose ability
to be such sexually active and and that
is an issue you know for men and
erectile dysfunction and for women
having other problems that may arise
with the actual act of sex but you know
what's what's interest of all there's
ways to deal with that you know now in
this day and age you know there's
there's um numerous interventions that
are very successful the erectile
dysfunction drugs for one thing of kind
of revolutionized you know male
sexuality in older years I think
education is important I think for older
people to understand that their bodies
undergo certain predictable changes
which might change the the actual
physical act of sexual intercourse but
which does don't preclude it and
sometimes just knowing what those
changes are for instance you know for
men just that they need to have actual
they don't get an erection just by
thinking about things the way they might
have in the past there has to be actual
physical stimulation it can take longer
certain phases of the sex
you know the sex act cycle are prolonged
so I think you know more knowledge can
be helpful but for a lot of older people
you know it's really not the sexual
intercourse part that's so important
it's really the intimacy the ability to
you know to touch to be physically
intimate as I said to have a partner so
you know there's a lot of issues but
what's interesting is that a lot of
older people are interested in having
some aspect of sexual expression whether
it's intercourse or not so and you know
that's coming out a lot more I mean I
think the baby boomers aging are kind of
throwing a whole bunch of things up in
the air and you know they're determined
to do it in a different way and they
don't want to be that frail person that
everyone thinks of when they think of
getting older so so they are you know
really kind of pushing the envelope in
terms of physical activity staying
healthy
you know aging well and you know being
sexually active into late years is I
think part of that so probably it's
going to just become more prevalent that
older individuals are interested in
being sexually active
there there are there are actually some
data that suggest that for instance men
who have and I can't give you the exact
numbers but men who have you know two
climaxes a week add so many years on to
their life so you know I don't know if
that's I don't know how good that
research data is it may very well be
that men who are able to have sexual
activity tend to be healthier and
therefore they live longer but but
having said that whether it's true or
not that that having sexual intercourse
a certain number of times gives you a
certain number of years of life I think
it's very true that you know the
engagement the social engagement the
interaction the meaningful Ness that
that sex and social engagement and being
connected brings to life that's
definitely been shown to not only you
know prolong life but also to greatly
enhance the quality of life however long
it is